well lots of
scary data on covert 19 scary charts and
things
but how worried should we actually be
let's go through some of
those data points and get a sense of
what's really going on it's worth saying
there's so much uncertainty about some
of these numbers but they are crucial
and we need to take a look at them and
work out just you know how scared
uh we should be and there is one line
one data point in particular that boris
johnson found very scary this just shows
you
daily cases by specimen date so this is
probably when you're looking at covert
charts this is maybe the one that you've
seen
first off number of cases uh in the uk
and that there was one day of data which
apparently swung that decision to go
for a lockdown on the 29th of december
over 80
000 new cases those were cases that were
recorded
on that day a striking figure a scary
figure
but it is worth saying a number that
perhaps is higher
than it should have been just because of
where it fell in the month that was the
29th of december and you've probably
guessed this already
29th of december the first working day
after
the christmas holiday so you had
christmas day there you can see a big
fall
obviously there but a lot of people the
expectation there's a lot
this is called generally speaking the
bank holiday effect after you have a big
period of holiday
you tend to see a big jump in activity
on the day after that
and that is possibly what's happened
here we'll have to have a look
but the effect of that might be to make
the shape of that increase look a little
bit scarier than it really is to make it
look like more of a kind of hockey stick
shape
whereas it could actually look slightly
more shallow
we'll have to see but if you take this
this data and kind of go back through
history
well it's clear you know that is a
hockey stick shape there isn't it this
is just cases going all the way back to
the start of this pandemic
and it's very clear there's a very
there's a kind of increase
around the kind of autumn period and
then you had that first lockdown then it
went down and then
potentially that's the new variant
coming in in the december period
but while it looks like we're in a much
worse position than we were in the
spring
bear in mind we are testing a lot more
at the moment than we were back
in the spring so a better way of
measuring the prevalence of this disease
is doing positive cases as a percentage
of total tests and if you do that
it is actually a slightly different
picture it's this line here
you can see a lot higher in the spring
the positivity
rate higher actually than we're at at
the moment and a bit steeper
too so while this line is certainly
going up this black line here showing
you percentage of positive tests
it is lower than it was in the spring
and perhaps
a little bit less steep and as i say
some of the kind of hockey stick
effect there might be down to the kind
of timing of christmas and where that
falls
we will have to see you know so much of
this data can change so quickly
um but that's a bit of kind of
historical context let's do a bit of
geographical context because some people
have been making out that the uk is in a
uniquely bad position around the world
that you know nowhere else has covered
quite as badly as we do here and while
certainly there is this new variant
it's worth just looking comparing our
positivity rate with other countries
uh to get a sense of of context so
ireland you can see actually starting to
rise quite sharply
uh more recently but a lower level uh
than england
uh germany kind of going up in the same
direction kind of getting towards
uh those kind of kind of actually kind
of getting more or less beyond where
they were
uh in the spring in germany uh and the
us
those numbers are slightly out of date
but they haven't kind of but
uh it has actually started to increase
since then but other countries and those
are all below the uk other countries
having a far worse pandemic right now
and the czech republic in other parts of
eastern europe is
really terrible and in south africa
going up very sharply indeed and the
point here is not really to to compete
it's not about a kind of league table
of covert and there are many other
countries which are doing a lot better
than than these ones
but to show that england isn't uniquely
very uniquely badly
at the moment it is kind of amongst
those countries which aren't doing very
well at the moment
and part of the reason for that as we
all know uh is down to this new variant
and one of the big questions i've been
wondering is how much is the new variant
of covert 19 contributing
to the spread of this disease and up
until now we haven't really had a sense
of that
but there has been new data just out
from the ons on this
showing you kind of the breakdown and
this line again it's the same kind of
thing
the total percentage of the population
which has the disease according to the
ons models and this is perhaps the most
definitive measure of it
and you can see that it goes up a bit in
the kind of uh october around that kind
of autumn period
and then rises much more sharply that
hockey stick that we see
in december how much of that is down to
the new variant of this disease well
they've broken it down you can see the
gray bit there is the old covert as it
were
and the white bit is new covered and yes
you can see look it's about
60 of all those new cases
are new covered this new variant of the
disease so certainly seems to be
responsible for a lot of that
growth in the virus and of course the
big question
now is what happens with all these cases
do we see hospitals filling up even more
do we see
more deaths well let's have a look at
the picture uh for hospitals
it's another one of those scary charts
that you might have seen recently
showing you covered patients in
hospitals across
the uk and perhaps you can make it out
here look at this
we're now above the april peaks so more
patients cover patients in hospitals
than there were in april and actually
this line here is for the uk
so it's kind of composite of all of the
different uh parts of the uk
but because some of the the some parts
of the uk including scotland take a
while to report the numbers
you don't really get a very up-to-date
picture so the more up-to-date numbers
for england so just england just that
white bit
show you that it's even higher now a lot
higher
than it was back in the spring so again
is this something we should be concerned
about well clearly it is that we're
seeing a rise
in the number of covered patients in
hospitals but again
some context back then in the spring it
certainly was high
but remember we weren't testing for
covert 19 as much as we are
now and so it's quite possible that what
we have there is a bit of an undercount
of the real situation it's quite
possible that while numbers are rising
fast at the moment
they still aren't where they are in
terms of the overall pressure on
hospitals as you had
uh in the spring we'll have to see again
it's worth just looking at but one way
of gauging just how much pressure there
is on hospitals is looking
at the amount of capacity the amount of
spare capacity across
hospitals and this shows you hospital
beds in england
generally acute hospital beds just in
england specifically and what you can
see here
is this black bit at the bottom is
covered patients and
certainly it is increasing you can see
that can't you but it doesn't look quite
as dramatic as it does when you're just
looking
at that covered series and you can see
that the majority considerable majority
of patients of beds are occupied by
non-cover patients so the idea of
this disease completely engulfing uh and
overtaking
all other uh all other kind of diseases
within hospitals isn't right
at all there is still some capacity you
see that slice at the top
unoccupied hospital beds but we'll be
keeping an eye on this over the course
of the next few weeks
also of course depressingly keeping an
eye on the number of deaths from
this disease at the moment they're still
relatively low compared certainly with
the spring
but the concern is that with cases being
so high they might increase as well
that will give us a more definitive
sense on how the disease has come back
and how big
of a second or indeed third wave this is
so stay tuned we'll have more data
in the coming weeks